i didn't really have any expectations i
you know because i had never really
done this with you well we didn't met a
couple times i don't remember in life i
don't remember
life where did we meet because was it a
cape event i i apologize i apologize
because they have said to me that we've
met before
i want to know where we've met and then
oh hollywood no the one
time the first time we met and then we
just kept seeing each other i mean
randomly not pepsi
like three times but at uh the clubs and
stuff but
it was that short film curious georgina
helen hong's um
that's right yes
now it now yes right yes i do remember i
was there when you were shooting your
scene because yeah
i do remember now but you love her
obsessed
obsessed we got to get her on the
podcast the hardest working
asian person i've ever seen oh she's
she's a she
is you know when um you know when i was
on the sitcom
yeah i'm flexing he was like he was
i heard the neighbor sneeze yeah
thank you thank you um
they hired somebody to play my sister
but i you know in my and then when
i saw helen hong when they hired her
i went uh i went up to her and i said
you're just like the hardest working
person because i knew her when she was
new
and for her to just crawl up
the ladder and to get to that place
goals
it just it just makes me feel so um
happy you know right because it's like
it's the time
it's a difficult it's a difficult
business to you know especially for
asians
easier for you guys i mean and listen
we're grateful for the people who paved
the way thank you you know what i mean
thank you
100 i'll always go back to that thank
you truly i'll always go back to that
like i do i didn't do
anything i know but i didn't do [ __ ] but
but you're right i do feel
lucky being uh in the industry right now
because it's like oh it is looking up
because we are you know unapologetic now
we're like
making sure the freaking world knows
that we deserve to be here all that
stuff so
anyway go go back to you were about to
compliment me you said you
you said you you don't think you were he
didn't think you were going to like me
yeah i i really don't know what that's
not i like it's just like i
was like you know usually when people do
our podcast it's somebody that i know
you know i've had dinner with and you
know everyone you know pretty much
i think we've had maybe two or three as
my mom would call it you have
intimate relationships i have intimate
relationships with people and so
you know i i don't generally like you
know ask people to do the podcast that i
don't really kind of know
because i don't want to be in a
situation where i'm going to ask the
wrong thing i don't know your
sensibilities but as soon as i saw you
out there
as soon as i met you i was like this is
going to work
bobby yeah because you like a dum-dum
you park your car
and then you got and i was standing
there watching you
and you just went the way you kind of
yeah i mean
why were you walking we have the same
she has an oompa loompa
yeah we have the same waddle yeah she
bottled
she's looking at her phone and she
waddles down the street
right she walks over and i'm standing
there like they're just going
i want to see where she goes so i won't
say anything
anything so i walked to the bottom of
the thing and i sat against that wooden
fence on across the street and i just
waited there
and then i see her go all the way down
the street and they come back waddle up
look at her phone and i went that's it
that's the one that's the one because
she is
you know she's uh you know no
honestly something's missing i will
absolutely i will absolutely play
uh your little sister i don't care let's
sign the contracts right now yeah
because i you know i
honestly don't you think yes on my
sitcom that she could play my little
perfect yeah perfect yep she's you're a
dead
dead-on so i want your show to fail
don't
watch it let's see yeah do not don't
we're going to bleep that [ __ ] show
that she's on
what if i'm just like a guest star
billed as a guest no no i need that
she's the third lead in the show just
give me the guest star money [ __ ] it no
no i need no we need her every episode
so we need you
we'll be in touch yeah yeah we'll be in
touch i mean that would be a killer cast
especially
because you know uh peter right peter
kim oh yeah they're friends yeah
yeah yeah wait so peter and i wrote it's
our show
i i love peter so much you know i
actually like um
wait i was i'll save it for later i mean
i don't know what i don't even know what
i was gonna say i just love peter so
much
you do um he's so funny and uh yeah i
remember
oh you know what's funny i'm sorry we
just cut out all this blabber yeah yeah
take it out cut it up make it pretty
yeah you know the drill never
never show my weakness george please um
i remember being at kill tony once and
then peter went up
and then you were on the um the judge i
was judging i was a judge
yeah and then you mentioned that uh
peter opened for you uh and all that
good stuff but he's so funny i adore him
we do a lot of the asian af shows
together and
yeah things like that you know he's your
your generation in terms of like
just people that i look at and i go wow
because when i started you know you i
don't want to name their names but
there were asian older asian comics
around sure but they
got by by doing the asia because they
have asian accents
and they know they kind of so
self-deprecating
you know i mean that it was like um they
didn't necessarily get laughs
through their their talent necessarily
people laughed at them because they
couldn't pronounce words
right or whatever right so that you know
when i came around it was like that's
what i'm competing against
right but now when i see like young kids
now coming up it's just like
they have such high skill right and such
talent you know i mean and the mugging
and and
and you know the switches all the stuff
is there
it just makes me feel um i threatened
right i get threatened
right right like a holy [ __ ] you're i'm
getting old or whatever
but like you know all i had was margaret
mm-hmm have you met margaret uh i you
would love she would love you
i i mean she's my [ __ ] queen she's
the best goodness gracious
we actually did a virtual show uh
together and it's funny because i was
watching her the entire time while i was
doing my set just to
just see if she was laughing she was she
was
um but we've technically met maybe in
person but like in passing
not not like a full-on one-on-one
conversation i i need that in my life
though i [ __ ] i mean she's
a vision board you know what i mean yeah
adore her well i i
you know you're one of those people that
i i would take you to whitney's house
because i think that you're
um i like you thanks bobby
truly that means a lot you're like a
yellow ball of pudge oh
i'm a gudetama yeah you seen those
little the egg little thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah like a you have ringo
hair yeah with the wrinkle hair yeah
yeah there's a gap in the market yeah
do we have an unhelpful advice